okay uh yes so so we'll continue and
next time I'll watch the time more
carefully and uh the next speaker is G
coin from prinstone and the title is
correlation Breakers Independence
reserving mergers and their
reputation hi everyone my name
is so this is the aort and please free
to ask any question during the talk um
so just kind of a conceptual story here
so back in the days before I was
academically born people many people
here actually ER tried to construct seed
extractors which was very sophisticated
object and it still is but it was
unattainable at the time and it has been
clear so this was introduced by Nissan
and Suman and gained a lot of attention
it has been clear that uh with we will
benefit by constructing objects that are
weaker by by expanding our toolbox in
order to solve this problem actually
devising a c extractor with good
parameters and for example two objects
were mergers which introduced by Amma
and condensers which were introduced in
a sequence of walks um and I want to
talk today about two objects I'll
actually Focus only on one during the
talk but I want to talk anyhow about two
objects that H proved useful maybe in
retrospective in order to construct the
newer objects that we tried to construct
like non meable extractors and therefore
by isan and David's reduction two Source
extractors Etc okay so so I just want to
describe these two objects I'm actually
going to talk just about one of them and
maybe at the end if you have some time
I'll the second one and I actually think
that you should look at this object by
itself I think it's a nice neat object
that might have other
applications if you just look at it in
isolation so that object is called
correlation break
is it big
enough
and so I'm going to tell you a story now
that you cannot make formal
mathematically but then we will we will
do so okay so the story when you when
you talk about correlation breaker the
story is the following you have a random
variable X which you like okay by like I
mean that that the underlying
distribution of this random variable is
is good so it belongs to some class of
good distributions okay maybe this class
of good distributions consist only of
the uniform Distribution on say n bit
strings or maybe it consists of all what
isan called NK sources by sources on n
Bits that had that has high Min entropy
say k anyhow you have this random
variable and which is good so you
reached your goal in some sense you
usually you don't start with this
variable you end with this varable you
do a lot of computation until you reach
that case but you know you reach your
goal but someone followed you right in
the sense that someone there someone
holds an adversary typically it sits in
the analysis it doesn't really there
someone holds a random variable X
Prime which could be any we should
correlate arbitrarily with X okay so the
way you should think about it is that
maybe X Prime is an arbitrary function
of your
variable okay
so I think of these are say n bit
strings supported on some fixed n bit
string it's not really important but
it's easier to think of it this way and
so f is some function that Maps n Bits
to end bits and it could be any function
it's not it catch it captures the
correlations between these two random
variables and I assume nothing about F
so for example it's not the case that X
condition on X Prime has entropy maybe f
is the identity
function maybe f is hard to compute Etc
okay f is an arbitary
function so okay so in particular it
doesn't have to sit in in D okay so you
have this nice
variable the ad some adversary holds
some some some information maybe all
information about your varable in some
some specific way and what you want to
do is to break these correlations this
is what you want to do so you want to
design a function let's call it a
correlation breaker
CB um and again you can formalize that
really but just still you know bear with
me such that if you will apply the
function on X to to the sample coming
from X you know you'll get something
right you get this new Rono variable
right and the guarantee that you want is
that if the adversary will apply the
same function your function that you
designed on his random
variable you cannot expect usually to
apply a function to his R variable
typically this is in the analysis so you
do theault experiment if the adversary
would have apply some the same function
on your variable you know he would have
gotten some
something like that and what you want is
that now not only that the output is is
nice it's nicely distributed in some
sense you want that the output is nicely
distributed even if you condition on
whatever the adversary got so one way to
write it is something like
that okay it makes sense so you want to
keep the nice
distribution even when condition on the
adversary is outut
and here you want one correlation that
works right so so clearly this is this
makes no you can't formalize that and
get any which is Meaningful because you
know whatever I'm writing here it fails
for f equals
identity yes but and we will see
specific instantiation of this which
turn out to be useful in a second but I
just think that if I'll start with that
we will miss the whole point so so this
why I'm saying that and this is still
annoying right it this this doesn't
exist this thing right because you know
regardless of no matter unless this the
you know empty set or something you can
do anything or I don't know what so but
anyhow this is this is the way you
should think about it so in some sense
the
correlations that are captured by F
should only H dictate which nice
distribution the output has but it must
be the case that it has an nice
distribution the output okay so F goes
only into which element here you equal
to um okay so now let me make it more
formal but I think it's keep good to
keep this conceptual picture in mind
okay so I'm going to describe to you uh
what we call the flipflop Primitive and
it instantiate this thing in a specific
setting which again turn out to
be the right one for many applications
for some of the applications we have so
here is so what's the flip flop
primitive
so so thetive is a function okay and it
gets us
input so this is essentially is going to
be what what is a nice distribution
right it gets an input a random variable
X which is an NK source so X is an NK
Source okay you think of n as the input
length really K is something we want to
minimize usually and X is an nend case
SCE and the flip also get what if you
want you can think of as a seed so these
are just you know some dbit string that
are uniform and if you just want to
write it somewh you can write it at D
Source okay D length string that has me
an entropy D which is uni
essentially so the flipflip also also
this this function I get this two input
but you can apply it in two different
modes mode zero and mode one if you want
so if you want you can think of a
someone entering a fixed bit either zero
or
one I'll Alpha to this
function and you know when you apply the
flip flop in mode alpha you get
something and when you apply the flip
flop in mode different Alpha you get
something in mode zero and mode you get
different functions so you can fig with
two functions if you want so the F
function has the following guarantee so
if you look at the output right which
will be know this way the guarantee is
the following the guarantee is if the
aders if some other will apply the same
function but with the different mode
okay one minus Alpha
okay to Any X Prime which is an nbit
string it doesn't have to be an NK
Source it doesn't have to havep any y
Prime which is a debit string let me
remove that
here then you know whatever you'll
get whatever he'll get should give you a
should essentially even when condition
that this should be good in the
following sense we really require that
the output when you apply your flip flop
even when conditioned on what happens
when you apply when the other applies
the same function but in the different
mode this thing should be uniform on
some number of bits that you care about
so let me just say what I mean here Prim
is a source is a c anything it's
anything so it's a d d zero it's a so
like here here we assume nothing about X
Prime right X Prime could have been any
random variable it doesn't have to be be
good so it's the same case here so X
Prime and Y Prime assume nothing about
them okay assuming that one is a
function of X and one is a function of Y
yes sorry this is critical yeah thank
you the only assumption that we have oh
sorry this is like the D thing here the
only assumption here is that this is a
product this product there is a product
distribution here in the sense that
sorry this is like the the main thing
some I forgot it my bad thanks for then
uh the only thing that we assume is that
x x Prime The Joint distribution of
these two un variables so X Prime could
be any function any function of X but we
want that the joint distribution should
be independent
of a y y Prime so particular X and Y are
independent but it's more than
that you know y Prime could arbitr
corate with Y and X Prime could X but
that's it so if you want you can think
of it as X Prime as a function of X and
Y Prime as a function of Y
same
thing okay so again so thanks so let me
just tell you how this falls down to
this category more or less so the good
distributions here are just a weak
source and an independent seed right
this is a good distribution so we want
we want them to be independent okay this
is a product here this functions could
be arit arbitrary I mean this could be
arbitrary function of this provided that
this that they maintain the independence
so this should be a function of that and
that should be a function of that and
guarantee is that well you know as as
look said you can't have one function
that does does it all so you have
actually if you want two functions or a
function with two modes it's I like to
think of this way better H such that as
long as you apply the functions in
different modes they kind of shift the
randomness in different directions right
they kind of make this output to be
uniform which is the notion of good for
the outputs here this output is uniform
even when condition on that
output okay is it clear
so any question about that maybe
just I'm sorry what does this last line
mean so it's conditioned on something as
uni you broke correlation so this should
be made a bit more formal than when
what's written so what you really want
is that so usually when you people WR it
they have their own meaning in head and
which is fine it's typically what I have
in mind anyhow but yeah you wanted this
random variable when you condition on an
average output from here should be close
no not on any fixing on on average and
here Alpha can be a function of X and Y
no okay so Alpha we think of alpha as a
fixed bit what really happens typically
is that you work hard to produce this
Alpha so this started in the work of
isan shin and V so they tried to
actually produce this Alpha from X and Y
and but then you have to I mean the flip
Works under the assumption that this is
constant so therefore you have to
guarantee somehow that you can fix it
while maintaining the nice guarantees so
for applications usually Alpha is not
fixed but I kind of want to isolate that
and when defining the flip flop I'm
assuming that Alpha is
fixed but right so it should hold for
both two conditions alal Z joint
distribution is statistically close to
this and uniform and those a joint
distribution right yes so you have you
have both cases one is just a bit you
need to wor about two things yes
typically Alpha is also longer which
make it in some sense harder to
construct these things as a function of
the length of alpha let's let's keep
alha equals a bit let's keep Al zo a bit
so you want to constuct these things so
it looks like it looks a bit like an
extractor in what sense you have a weak
Source you have a seed you output
something which is uniform right um in
particular this is an extractor it's
longer than exor because if you want to
construct an extractor and someone gave
you a flip-flop which doesn't happen
then what you can do is just for example
you know just to make sure everything
just for S Check really you can just do
that right so the guarantee that this
that this thing by the guarantee of the
flip flop this thing is uniform even in
condition on whatever what what you what
will happen if you apply the same
function to say x y and one or to
whatever and so in particular the
marginal is uniform right so definitely
a flip flop is stronger than extractor
we actually use extractor inside the
flip flop um but you know the extra
guarante is
crucial well you can even extract double
you canate x y z and X Y right you can
do better that's
true like that that's that's a good
point you can do that even because these
two are independent
right um
okay so let's see let's still play
around this definition I hope I hope you
you kind of I don't know understand the
need for this conceptual definition and
maybe don't understand the need for that
specific instantiation but understand
that this is an
instantiation
um and uh let's see so what you should
expect so let's say that we only want to
Output one bit okay it's hard enough
usually in this cases outputting one bit
is the hard part anyhow uh sometimes you
can even make this for one okay so so
say you just want to Output one bit so
the go the goal is the following your
given end this is the input
length oh your given n and what you want
to do is to minimize the entropies
required for this proced to for this
procedure to work right you want to
minimize the entropy of your Source X
and the seed length d right you want to
have this guarantee you want for any end
to conu such a function the trans poly
and time when D and K is as small as
possible because these are just kind of
help random that you have
so any guesses to how much D should be
uh just play with it so L at least Logan
right exactly it should be at least
Logan one way to see just because you
know flip flop gives you an extractor
and we know that extractors require
entropy Logan s of s of length Lan
regardless of K but intuitively if you
don't know doubt and this is more or
less how you start to prove such a thing
you would say that if the S length is
smaller than Logan say Logan minus one
to base two then you the see can only
touch half of the entries of the source
right and so maybe the entropy lies in
the other half of the source so you can
couple a CD in a s that cause trouble to
the extractor so this why this should be
L again it turns out to be
enough up to addtive constant which I
don't care
about and so now the harder
question how big K should
be I give 10 checks to anyone who knows
that but for amnon isan David
sh up I don't
want so under the same the same argument
what should K
be so you see so you look at this you
say well you know okay we use the seed
why in order to in some sense access the
entropy of the source X but it's also
the vice versa right so you want to use
the entropy of the source in order to
access why because otherwise it seems
you you won't be able to exploit the
fact that you have actually in some you
can only exploit it in One Direction in
some sense so it turns out that K should
be at least log D which is log
Lan okay so a potic method will give you
that also it will match that so it turns
out that the best function like that
would require but that's enough to
require logarithmic C and dou
logarithmic okay and uh the flip
primitive is a is an explicit
construction that gives you these
parameters so there is an explicit
construction that I'll try to describe
in the remaining of the time that I have
that with that c length for that
entropy establish this uh guarantee you
assume is a Conant right you assume epon
right so I assume yeah sorry I assume EP
is a constant the dependence in Epson is
what you expect is plus L one in every
place yes and and the flip flop gives
you
those G if you
if you wanted a construction with very
poor parameters like k n/2 d being of n
would it be a simple way of doing
it seems difficult for any parameter
so okay so the flip gives you kind of
essentially immedately n extractor so
above above n over two which is the area
where everything is kind of easy I guess
you can do something easier uh below
that like strictly below not below that
I think it's I don't know how to do it
actually try to make it
simpler it's not too complicated you
will see it's not crazy and random here
is obvious so if should random because
the alphas right so for non manable
exactal when do to prove the existence
of these
functions it
was everyone at the end of the day can
do it but it wasn't easy it wasn't
trivial at all here because you have
different Alpha and Alpha Prime
if you take random functions they behave
on this one and it's obvious
yes and this is another way to prove the
existence of non member extractors also
which is easier gives you better
parameters also but uh but anyhow let me
show you TR also it will be this
parameters yes yes yes yes plus the
two plus some constant yes yes yes in
both of them
um okay so uh
yes so now I want to give you an
explicit construction that does that and
the reason I want to do it is because I
want to show you what goes into this
constructions what do we do when we wake
up in the morning and how do we argue
about these things but before that I
just want to say that right these things
is that you know there exist you know
the way you write it is that there exist
a function a fop that has these
parameters and just want to introduce
Ann notation that I like to introduce
all the time hope it will catch up at
the end so if you want to say that
something exist explicitly you if you
want you can write it this
way so okay yeah usually
the US Chinese yeah in Chinese it means
a king yeah you need to make this a
little bit smaller but then it takes
a okay which was by design of
course uh okay so in order to consite
this F primitive we're going to use
what I like to call hierarchy of
Independence so let me tell you what
that is
okay so so no question so far just kind
of curious because it's nothing it's all
clear okay so aty of Independence so so
say you have say you have the same
scenario of X and the adversary has X
Prime and you also have Y and Y ADV has
this y Prime that may correlate with Y
arbitrarily and X Prime mayate with cor
xarly but you know no Crossings here and
hierarchy of Independence it's really
just a pair of functions little a and
little B so let me write it this way so
it takes a and b both A and B so let me
just abbreviate both A and B takes an N
bit string which is going to be X or X
prime a dbit string which is going to be
y or Y F and you're going to Output some
string don't worry about its length so
much let's just call it B it's not
important why it's a bation
yes and I use MAF RM here
so
so so the guarantee of this little a and
little B these are these are strong
functions they have little names are
strong functions the guante of this
function is the following if you're
going to compute a
little a applied to X and Y which you
call Capital a this new variable which
is just little a applied to X and Y and
little sorry and little B applied to X
and Y which you're going to call the
resulting variable you're going to call
capital B and the adversary is going to
play the same game he's always doing
what you're doing so he's going to
compute a prime which is a the same
function apply to X Prime and Y Prime
and B Prime again the same function
apply to X Prime and Y Prime
so you're going to have the following
nice guarantee so you kind of forget
about the
excess and look at look at these three
random Vari these three pairs of random
variables what we you will have is the
following you will have that
a which sits I think of this as hierar
level in the hierarchy so this is the
lowest level medium and highest highest
level so a which sit higher than y and I
prime this random variable is going to
be uniform even when condition on on y
Prime okay so you want to break
correlations but what this gives you is
a way just you know I'm going to say
something else in a second but it gives
you a way to produce a list of R
variables of length three the input A
and B such that higher level ROM
variable that sits higher level in the
AR are better in the sense that they
uniform conditioned on lower level
variables so we are going to have that a
is even when condition on y Prime is
uniform we wish that a would have been
uniform condition on a prime because
that that that does it right it's not
the case it's just the case that if you
if you look at a lower level random
variables in the hierarchy you get this
guarantee and same for B so B is going
to be uniform condition a prime and also
y Prime
so let me just add it for
fun
okay
so the way to realize this is by Alterna
instruction you see extract to do so but
it's not the point the point is that
what you get out of it what you get out
of it is a way to break correlations but
in this hierarchial sense Gil is a prime
uniform given y also or that just okay
maybe X Prime and Y Prime are just fixed
to constants oh fix to right we have no
guarantee on what happens if theary but
it is the case that if X and Y are are X
is Cas is uniform it is the case that
Prim is uniform yes but if you assume
nothing I mean the adversary could could
apply the functions to weird run
variables just to make sure what you
just said follows syntactically right I
mean if x there is no difference between
X1
and right yes yes yes yes yes yeah you
can
yeah um okay but okay so so you have
these two
rules I mean you know I won't show how
you construct this little little B but
this this F of bi instruction it was it
appeared in the leakage paper by I hope
I pronounced the name correctly janovski
and Pac each of the names however and
then by dois and vix they used it
heavily and then Shin Le used it in some
more sophisticated ways Etc but we are
going to use it differently so there is
this little a and little B this D
function which I there exists an
explicit function like that okay okay I
just say that a is an extractor kind of
by definition little a and little B
turnes out you can apply you can you can
actually implement it using free smart
applications of
extractors okay so everything here boils
down to C extractors but conceptually
it's better to think of it as as
functions that give you this this
property and that's
it okay so you have this A and B how
would you get the output how do you get
something which is uniform in condition
on the adversaries because you don't
know to pick B and then ask the
adversary if he's kind enough to pick a
prime right you can do
that okay so so here's the
idea so maybe I should verify how much
time do do I have here
sorry but maybe I should just verify is
is it okay is it clear these two
functions what they produce Etc and the
problem that we have left is how do we
make use of this A and B if we don't
know which to choose right with you know
um so are you trying to go from this to
a foot yes okay right I'm trying to
essentially what pictorially I'm trying
to get from this to one column in which
this is uniform condition on that not
going backwards right
um yes so so here is here is the idea so
you have X and
Y right you have X and and Y and the
adversary has X Prime and Y Prime and
initially we're going really
to essentially to compute A and B as
written there so a is going to be
application of X and Y you really need
to not use all of Y just the first you
know part of it or something to in order
to make sure that you keep some entropy
there but don't worry about it
essentially use X and Y uh and also you
compute this random variable B so I'm
going to describe you the FP when it
applied to Alpha equals 1 and then I'm
going to describe to you what happens
when you apply to Alpha equals sorry
zero and then with alals one so when
alha equals z you're doing the following
you you're Computing this little a and
little
B and the adversary is follows you right
so we applies the same function but to
his run no
variables and then you you say well okay
I'm just I'm just well I draw it on the
bo but I'm just going to use I'm just
going to use when Alpha equal Z I'm just
going to use this guy okay I'm
essentially not going to computer just
wrot it for us to look at it but for the
analysis I'm not going to use I'm just
going to compute this guy and when Alpha
equals z if you think of it the
adversary will when it operates of
course Alpha equals
one we are going to set F that when
equals one he's going to use this guy so
the alpha it tells you which A or B to
use when Alpha equals z use a when Alpha
equals 1 use B and I'll describe why we
win the adversary when Alpha equals z
and he uses Al equal one but it's the
same D
way okay so I'm kind of describing the
of the analysis and the construction I
guess in same times hope that's okay so
you have X and Y you choose a the choose
B Prime if you would apply the function
equal one you would have chosen B and
then would have Chen a okay now this is
this is the one phase now we are going
to try to come up with a function C
we'll see what we need from this
function so this going of phase one now
we are not going to just output a or
prime that makes no sense we are going
to take we're going to to apply some
function C it turn on to be an extractor
also but for different reasons so I'm
not going to say that too much so we're
going to take C and apply it to x y and
a and the adversary is going to apply
the same function that we need to design
and think what we need from it when
apply to X Prime y Prime and B
Prime
right uh and and we are calling you're
calling whatever we got
y a
flop and his the other is getting y
Prime flop so maybe I should in
retrospective should say that we think
of this as a flip B flip B Prime flip a
prime flip and now we are going to be in
the Flop state this way it's called flip
flop so so now we are going to do the
same thing but instead of using Y and Y
Prime we're going to use y flop and Y
Prime flop okay so now we are going to
apply the same functions literally and
literally
again so we are going to so now think of
it as follows you start with X but y
flop and the aders has X Prime and Y
Prime flop and now we're going to
compute a
flop which is little a with X but with Y
flop not
y okay we'll see in a second why it's
kind of okay and B
flop is the function B applied to X and
Y
flop and the adversary is going to do
the same he's going to get some a prime
flop which is a applied to X Prime and Y
Prime flop and similarly B Pine flope
let write it down
because and of course what will happen
now is that we are going to use the the
alpha to choose the other thing so in
this case we are going to choose this
thing to be the output this is the
actual
output and when yal 1 well this is the
scenario where the adversary applies
Alpha equal 1 we're going to Output that
guy
okay so why does this work why does this
make sense even just even so so here's
the thing if if indeed Alpha equal Z is
is the model of operation that we apply
and the adversary app one this is
exactly what depicted
here then initially we don't start so
well we we choose a flip and then work
with it later on you put it back into C
Etc but we choose a flip and the
adversary choose be Pine flip which is
kind of bad because we want to choose
the B1 because it it's better than the a
right so in this case if the adversary
wants he can actually break the
correlation with you which he doesn't
want but he could do that so this
doesn't look so good so on the other end
in the second phase because we started
bad badly we can actually we are
guaranteed that we are going to choose
this guy so all and the adversary is
going to choose that guy so all we need
to make sure from C is that well if x is
an end case Source Y is a weak Y is a
seed and a is uniform just by itself not
independently of B Prime then this
should be uniform just by itself because
if that holds which is a very weak
condition I mean it says that if this is
uniform this is a weak s and this is
uniform this should be just uniform
there is a very easy way to do that so
if that
holds then at the beginning of the
second phase we we have the same
assumptions we had initially but with
this new variables and then we are
gaining the independence B flop is going
to be uniform even condition aine flow
right so this is a good thing if we
start badly we just need to make sure we
don't end at the at the halfway too
badly and then we are fine just easily
so a a reasonable application of an
extractor will do that even just output
well when the way it looks like that
just output a or something but but it's
not what should
work the harder case is to to say what
happens when you actually start good but
then end up taking the bed the bed one
so say now so like n said say say that
this this is us and this is the
adversary right so now X Prime is X
Prime is an N Cas SCE y Prime is uniform
I just don't want to switch the Cycles X
Prime is an Source y Prime is uniform
and this is the aders okay don't don't
get attached to the
primes so what happens you see you start
very well you start with a random
variable which is unform even when
condition so I like to do it this way
it's uniform even when condition on that
one now you just just want to preserve
the
independence right throughout the scen
throughout the the the remaining of of
the process which doesn't is not obvious
that you can do because you see you
chose this varable which is better than
that but then maybe the adversary could
kind of undo what you're doing because
he even chose which is better than yours
and it might be the case that you know
the sum the sums are the same right you
you win nothing so it so let's see so
what do you need to make sure happens so
from C we need to make sure that
in this case where this thing is uniform
even condition that it's it's be crucial
to make sure that even though this
depends on that and this depends on that
it will make sure that to make sure that
once this Independence is obtained it's
preserved okay so once the for variable
in of C is good condition on the other
guy the output should also be
good and this St out extractors fulfill
in some in the sense that we need it
here
here so we need to make sure that the
fact that this is uniform even condition
that implies that this is uniform even
condition so we want to start better
than we usually start this process we
want to start with y y Prime flow being
uniform in condition y flow but that's
not enough because maybe it's the case
but then you know maybe maybe this is so
much more independ that so that you get
canceled so you want to make sure from
Little a and little B you want to have
the following property
that okay maybe it's the case that
always B is better than a in the sense
that it's uniform condition on a but you
want that if you apply A and B in such
scenario where the two this this seed is
independent of that seed then it doesn't
matter then the when the the this
propagates and the the correlations are
not suddenly reappear here and again
because A and B coming from extractors
and extractor has this average nonm
property I don't know how to call it
then this holds also so I haven't told
you what little a little B little C is
and in fact you know the thing is that
this is challenging because because of
the details what you really need to make
sure here is is that little a little B
little C play nicely and fall under this
category but they do and uh you know you
can you can read the papers if you
want um so any questions about that
SP so in terms of Primitives that you
put together to get this Construction
it's just C extractors with no extra
it's just C extractor so this is one
application of extractors this is free
see is one and this like again one so
eight nine applications and that's it
maybe maybe less because you use a and
then b or
something so it's really just amounts
but I think that if you read it and
don't conceptualize why use this and why
this there it's confusing more confusing
and so for me at least so uh so now you
go to the you know go to your table and
try to see how to implement that but I
think that's what you should
Implement any other questions before I
if I have five look ahead
soe you know you use this look ahead
extractor but you're saying you're
trying to strengthen it so in one case
it's not just entropy but it's like
uniform in the other case Yes actually
maybe maybe I should maybe I should have
started with that sorry so so dois andx
had a an idea that defin
would have influenced that had I know
the
idea and it says the following it says
say you have not justed a and you have a
you can you have this little function a
B I think it will answer little C and
Little D where it's the same thing as
you imagine the A's are the B's are
better than the A's and the C's are
better than the B's and the A's and the
D's are better than the a B's and C's
okay so now you'll have if you had these
and you you can just do that actually
this is how it started then then here is
a a very cool idea so you you just you
you take all the four the adversary take
all is four but then you do something
very nice you take you take A and D Alp
equals 1 and if Alpha equal zero say you
take B and C so the adversary in this
case will take B Prime and C
Prime and the claim is it's kind of far
easier to see but it's it's enough
sometimes it's super cool is that each
of them has at least half the entropy
condition on the other one it's not that
a d is uniform condition B Prime C Prime
but it's that A and D when you condition
this as average me entropy which is
roughly half and the reason is the
following so so why a d are kind of
better than b Prim C Prime in that sense
well you know B Prime and C Prime gives
you only information about a so D even
when you condition on these two it left
the entropy it's just even uniform so
it's definitely the case that the a has
Min entropy half so if the good output
distribution is not if you don't insist
it to be uniform but only entropy half
when when this is in that direction it
gives you that in the other Direction so
why condition a d b Prim C Prime are
fine well a does nothing but then D
could mess some some part of Prim C
Prime but it couldn't be too much
because the length of it is just half
the length of the both together so this
is a and if you look at this it's kind
of so you just make sure that
you so it's not just entropy requirement
just you kind of protect if what
whatever you got if you got it yes uh
and this this led to uh privacy
amplification
protocols two privation protocols that
were the reason why people introduce why
do this in introduce this notion of non
meable extractors which the flip flop is
a central primitive in
yes so you know how to construct it I
mean so what's the state of the art and
flip lops everything is optimal or no no
so in flip Lop uh everything everything
is is a is fine because we have great
extractors that we can use so we really
lose nothing the only thing that's open
and this is why we have so many little
logs everywhere going around is because
you don't get to apply the flip flop you
the flip flop is is a is a nice case
where the advice length that this the
fixed thing that is different from the
other guy is of length one so typically
you can't make it of length one
typically what happens is it length poly
logarithmic or logarithmic in epsilon
and one Epsilon and which makes it and
then you want to be efficient in terms
of this a so we we show that it's enough
to consider a which is log epon you can
forget about n that's one thing and then
the question is how you can make H how
we can make this so one way is to kind
of apply the flip flop sequentially
throughout the bits of the the advice
make sure it's fine but this cost linear
in the advice length so shin and I and
isan and in a bunch of papers we made
the dependence in a logarithmic in a or
maybe maybe this is shin I think I did
Lo ah Shin did this thing and I did this
thing or something and I don't I don't
what is a now a is different a is advice
a is advice length yes so when it's one
you don't see the problem there is no
problem but you are going to use the
flip flop in different ways in order to
make sure that if the if the alpha is
not a bit but many bits then in
different ways you get better and better
dependence on dependencies so this this
is this goes into the C length and the
entropy required from the extractor so
you want this thing to be a smallest
function of a it should be log a it
should be additive log a this time it's
multiplicative
but um oh sorry we made it additive but
it still it looks like that so the the
only thing left is to remove this one we
have partial results but so is it
possible to State uh I guess bigger
Alpha like a clean property Al Zer but
yes so what you wanted initially was a c
length which so let's keep Epson
constant because we don't cheat there so
so this so D and K were roughly like
that so let's not worry about K because
it's really it's always smaller than D
so what D is so it should be log n plus
log a and unfortunately it's so Le has
the best construction at this point
something like
that and a is typically a what we showed
it's almost log one
epon which is kind of weird because yes
and and and then epon is usually one
over n so you get this
annoying log n Times log l
expression sorry apologize I mean I
think this is really I mean this would
be the second question that I was asking
but just to make sure so what would be
the I just want to make sure I
understand the definition of flip flope
is oh the definition not the
construction yeah just the this would be
I would have as this questions so it's
good with the answer yes okay so
answering your second question I should
but just just to make sure that I
understand the
definition right so so the flip Lop the
correctly the way it's defined is a
function that gets an nbit string a seed
and an seed and an advice which we just
considered a bit but now consider it as
a some some a bit string and the
guarantee should be that for any NK
Source X I move in a second sorry NK
Source X
and a d uniform dbit strings or DD I
don't know Source Y and X Prime and Y
Prime that and for any Alpha not equal
Alpha
Prime the a bit
strings sorry to doing that now they're
independent of X and Y for now just
Alpha and Alpha Prime are just not equal
yes
but and Y can okay yes exactly so you
yeah in the one bit case it was kind of
and this is why I prefer to think of it
as one function not many
functions yes
and
yes yes uh so you said kind of the X
Prime sometimes follows along in the
analysis how exactly are these used like
is it for anal or like why why do we
have these why do we why X is on X you
mean for example are these correlations
Breakers what are they useful in
specific constructions of things or just
in analysis and how I see I see so for
example sometimes you may have two
random
variables say x and x prime or Y and Y
Prime and and these are two random
variables that you obtained in such a
way that Y is uniform and Y Prime could
be anything it happens more often than
you think and then what you want is just
to merge them just to make them one
random variable and in that case you
would say just you know if computer
science just pick the bitwise parity of
the fing just add them up in some field
uh but you can because there are
correlations right so what you want to
do is to buy the correlations you you
apply this thing you apply the
correlation to this thing with Alpha
equals z this Alp equals one so you see
the dependency here come from from
depend here but more generally it's yeah
there like maybe five different ways of
using this in some of them y Prime you
don't have it you just in the analysis
in some cases it's like
that okay let's say thank you
for
yeah you can ask further questions in
the uh in the break and we now have a
break until
[Music]